hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled rna bead-based assays to
detect tumor gene amplifications in
blood-derived exosomes this webinar is
part of the cell bio2021
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
luminex
for more information about luminex go to
www.luminexcorp.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation and if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on the help desk button
located at the bottom of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education's credit link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits
without further ado
i'd like to present our speaker today dr
godfrey gretch an associate professor
with the department of pathology faculty
of medicine and surgery at the
university of malta for a complete
biography of our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr greg welcome you may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much for the invitation
to present at the cell biology 2021
event
today i will be taking you through the
part from basic research in cell biology
and where we actually
measure and study specific
mechanisms of disease in oncology
and moving towards actually detection
of these characteristics
in
blood
using
blood derived
exosomes
as extracellular v skills
that are being shared by
cells
so these are the this is the part that
we actually take
and of course we start off with basic
research where we study the cellular
biology and the mechanism of disease
and once we have
identified specific
biomarkers that will give us information
that can predict disease or
one therapy therapy outcome
or actually biomarkers that can be used
to monitor patients
then we trigger immediately the part
towards validating these biomarkers
using
patient material
patient data
and with all this information we will
translate
into
a pipeline a workflow
in which we can actually then measure
these power markers depending on the
specific question
so ultimately we will validate these uh
diagnostic or catagnostic biomarkers
eventual commercialization
now
our group have we have been studying the
uh
particular phosphates the phosphate is
protein 2a pp2a
pp2a is
a complex a phosphate is complex
made up of three subunits you have the a
structural subunit
and you have the b which is a regulatory
subunit and this is which is the
catalytic subunit
and this complex um
is directed towards specific targets
in this case i'm showing that the
targets are actually
the um pi3k act m tour
pathway and they dephosphorylate these
targets
now when the complex
is inhibited
this particular
mechanism this particular
signal transduction is sustained
and promotes survival proliferation and
also differentiation block
now previous studies we showed that
specific proteins and these are actually
regulators so
it's one of these subunits but in this
case these are inhibitory regulators
of this particular complex and our
journey started with actually
identifying
the role of alpha 4 or also known as
igbp one in shifting the phosphatase
activity towards different targets but
away from the mtor pathway
resulting in differentiation block
that was shown on
erythroid
progenitor model
today we know a lot about these
inhibitory subunits alpha 4 is one of
them
set has been shown to be extremely
important in glass crisis in chronic
myeloid leukemia
and sib2a has gained a lot of
interest
in
solid tumors
and this is where we are currently
working with
septuay by over expressing it in various
cell lines and studying the feedback
mechanisms
in various cellular models
in fact we have now and at hand cellular
models which are breast cancer
cell lines
which we constitutively
expressed
shipped away
and we looked into the
phosphor profiling due to the effect of
this over expression
[Music]
so the importance of pp2a in
breast
cancer
let us let us to
looking at
the sensitivity of cell lines in this
case i'm showing the triple negative
breast cancer cell lines
and their sensitivity to pp2a activator
fty 72o
now as you can see in these graphs so
the
graph a
shows
tmbc cell lines that are sensitive to f
to y 7 to o there is the percent cell
viability on the y axis
and on the x axis we find the
concentration of f to y 7 into o
and you can
actually appreciate that these three
cell lines in figure a
show that you can actually reach the
ic50
and add very low
dosages of fty 720 two of which even
less than one
micromolar
whilst the tmbc cell lines in figure b
show that they are not sensitive
to f2y seven to o
and with one of the sidelines showing
that there is a change or there is an
ic50 reached at 10 micromolar
f2y72
and so basically here we can see that
there are three ambient sunlights that
are sensitive and those that are
non-sensitive and actually we studied
further these
six cell lines
as two groups
and so we can see that we have the
ndamb231
reaches an ic50 at one micromolar b20 at
very low dosages of 0.1 micromolar
and hs570 at 5 micromolar
and we compared these two cell lines
using transcriptomic
datasets so we did rna sequencing
experiments to look at differential gene
expressions between these two groups
and from these transcriptomic analysis
we identified a list of potential
markers
that are associated with sensitive and
sidelines to f2y720
our understanding was our hypothesis was
that these
markers are actually markers of low pp
two-way
activity and hence we continued with the
experiments showing and we actually
showed that these sensitive cell lines
have very low
pp2a activity
which i will show in a minute
and as compared to non-sensitive
and then we utilize these
differential express genes into
multiplex
panels
to compare these cell lines and even
move on to patient material
so as part of the multiplex panel that
we actually selected we added the
subunits of pp2a and here we can see
that we added the
ppp2ca which is the catalytic subunit
and the blue boxes
then we have also regulatory subunits
the r2a which is the light blue
and also the inhibitors set
set binding protein 1 sip2a and amp32a
and
when we look at this data set in which
we are here the figure shows normalized
expression to housekeeping genes and
compare as a group of salva is the
non-sensitive too sensitive
and the distribution of the pp2a complex
and its regulators we have
a slight significance
of sift away high in the sensitive group
but this data shows us that it is
extremely difficult to compare
the markers at group levels so the
sensitive as a group and demand
sensitivity group i'm saying this
because if you then look at specific
cell lines we can see that the
231 breast cancer cell line
actually has a very high expression of
c2a
while in the case of bt-20 we see a very
low level of the r2a
subunit meaning that different cell
lines would have
different deregulation
and parameters for the pp2a complex
hence this
shows us that it's extremely important
to look at the different cell lines and
also when we look at a group of cell
lines and eventually patient material we
definitely would need to have a
multiplex panel
in which we we have all the subunits
that
that show the complex but also
addition of
um
a panel of markers that show low pipito
activity and in fact that is
what we were
after
and therefore we moved on to
multiplexing
and we use this quantity in plex assay
from thermo which works
on the xmf technology
and using duluminux platforms
so the luminex xmap b based multiplexing
can go up to 80 genes in this particular
experiment we started with 40 genes
it is a nucleic acid sandwich
hybridization method
in which you have
your target that you want to capture
then you would have
different capture beats
specific
probes and capture extenders which would
specifically bind to one of the targets
of interest
now once it is bound to the speed
then through label extenders
a dna scaffold
is used
in which using a pre-amplifier and
amplifiers you will have this whole
scaffold of labor probes which would
eventually
and through streptavidin pe
and would eventually give us a signal so
basically here what we're doing is
we are not
amplifying the target as we do with pcr
here we actually amplifying the signal
and then using the luminex platforms we
measure the
fluorescence
now
why we want we want to go for
multiplexing it's basically because cell
biology is dynamic cell biology is
complex
and
when you look at some of the
sun lines that we used and we here we
divide them as primary cell lines and
metastatic sunlights
those that are
sensitive to
fty72o are marked with an asterisk here
and you can already see that this
sensitivity is not based
on
the expression of epithelial markers
because
here you see ecatherine and epcam
this is the median fluorescent
insensitive that we get from the luminex
so this is normalized to housekeeping
genes
um and and here you can see that these
are epithelial because you have
expression of
ear catheterion and and appcam
why is the others are not
so
this this is only showing two of the
plaques
we looked at this is the same
graph but now i'm extending the scale
here
and here you see like if we look at
specific mesenchymal markers like ncat
hearing like n cut here in snipe one
snap2
fn1 and twist you can see that
now this shows up as a messenger marker
cell line
and that is
sensitive to f2i720
when we look at
vimentin which is another
marker
we see that this is positive
fundamentals and it's always the same
but we are scaling it up to see
the
markers
so this shows the importance of actually
having
um
multiplexing
so that you actually have a good
classification so these are called
classifiers
of the different cell line models
that we use
using only one
marker or two
and that would not provide us with the
food information
so coming back to our interest to show
the low pp2a activity what we did is we
compared these groups at a
transcriptomic
level and we
identified
differentially expressed genes between
sensitive and non-sensitive
here on the left you see a graph in
which we actually pulled down the
complex
and
measured the activity the phosphatase
activity
against
a substrate in vitro
and
as you can see the sensitive have low
pipital activity and the non-sensitive
have high but this is something we
cannot do
on patient material of course we can do
it on cell lines but not really on
patient material and therefore we wanted
to find this marker that
discriminates between these activities
here we just add this as a positive
control because we know that k562 has
have actually low phosphatase activity
so when we did all this transcriptomic
and checked the the networks and g
networks
we encountered this particular
panel
and we put our interest in aurora kinesi
and kiev2c
as the
markers
when they are highly expressed
then we will we always have a low p2a
activities in our cell lines and of
course we extended studies with
inhibitors and activators
and we looked at all
all the possible um designs to show that
our current gift to see are really
excellent markers for low repeat way
activity
and you can see it here okay so our
these are non-sensitive and sensitive
and this is the activity corresponding
activity
[Music]
so then once we actually found this
micro said okay how important this
marker is in the context
of breast cancer patient tissue
and here where we started using
the publicly available data sets in this
case dtcga
and here we're looking at rna sequencing
normalized expression values
um looking at matched
normal to tumor so we only looked at
those samples in which they have matched
moment and tumor and we compared the
expression of alkali and give to c
alkyne yellow and give to c and that
they seem to move always together but
the most important is
that there is an increase in these
markers when comparing normal to tumors
so that was already very interesting to
see
more interesting is that you have a
higher magnitude and luminal b and which
is known to be the more most aggressive
and high in k67 proliferation marker
and also in bazel so this is very
interesting to see that we we actually
have markers that shows us a
difference between tumor and mesh normal
and the difference of types
of course we also
did a lot of work on our tmbc patient
material
and to our surprise our car is expressed
uh at a high level in
more than 72 percent of tnbc patients
here we use the minimalist chemistry on
ffpe whole sections
we did the age scoring and we use 160
cases for this particular experiment and
here you can see the increase in the
eight scores of rural kainenese
[Music]
now
we kept on looking at
some important data sets as well and
here again we move on to the tcga data
set this is something that we've
seen from our ffpe material where we saw
a correlation between the expression of
our car and one of the inhibitors of
pp2a
in breast cancer patient
and this was a correlation between our
concept2a and here we extended this to
also tcga datasets where we show here in
the left
that our
messenger in the expression
correlates with the expression of ship
to a
which is quite
significant
now
it's a well-known fact as well that
our car is amplified in
various concerts
um and in fact the
copy number variation
and correlates
excellently with the tpx2 gene that's
because they are on the same chromosomal
region and they are in generally
amplified together
i'm saying this because we did a lot of
work on the on gene amplifications in
various cancers there's a high frequency
of these amplifications and today we
know a lot about gene amplifications
so
we started this uh project
this project what we did is
again we wanted to go for multiplexing
so not really studying one so we do a
simultaneous analysis of various gene
signatures
and
during the expiratory we used even 40
pluses
we looked at these common amplified
genes in crc within an 18 multiplex
essay
when we looked at
those that are involved in metastasis
and
invasiveness
and also therapeutic resistance
this is a specific cohort of crcs
and this is patient cohort of crcs
both primary tumors
and matched
biopsies from metastatic lesions
so it's really a very specific cohort
meaning that these have
already had a metastasis but we went
back to the dark the primary tumor and
also we actually had the metastatic
lesion
um both
in ffpe so for me fixed peripheral
embedded it's good to say that with the
quantity let's say we can actually run
ffbes because it's not that
you can actually read these
gene amplifications and gene expressions
in this case
and
using
even degraded material
so here we show that there's a huge
amount of tpx2 represented in this
particular group of patients
so tpx2 was
overexpressed
at an mrna level okay um which is for us
reflects that there
is a gene amplification
so overexpressed compared to the normal
colon
then if you take tpx2 fz d1 and igf2 we
have all the cohort together so that's a
nice panel for these specific types of
tumors
and then we looked at the metastatic
lesions where we find 50 percent of
crc's
moving to the lung showed a very high
expression of top 2a
and
ccnd3 and cyclin d3 was
overexpressed in lung metastasis
those that are exclusively found in
liver metastases cdx2 and kit in this
case and make was found consistently
gained in metastasis over the primaries
in
all
the types
now okay so we had sort of an idea of
the
gene amplifications at primary and
metastatic and then i wanted to move on
with other projects to really look at
innovative molecular profiling gases
to look at distinct circulating tumor
cells and also exosomes
we wanted to develop an actionable panel
multiplex panel
for these circulating
cells or vesicles
okay so i'm not going to take a lot of
time here so liquid biopsies you have a
solid tumor and these will shed
exosomes you have to have there's also
orthotic bodies dna rna okay and cell
free rna and ctcs so these are all
the different ways how we can measure it
we focused on citizens but in this
particular presentation i will focus on
exosomes now in general exosomes are
used to read micrornas in our case we
used it to read messenger and the
expression
to reflect gene amplifications which
originate in the primary tumors
ctcs as you know can be
put down with
appcam antibodies although in our
research we also showed that some of
them are becoming negative so
and here again
putting multiple
antibodies would be
necessary
depending on the patient
and
first we wanted to look again into the
amplifications in the crcs so we have
cell lines we have blocks
so we have a whole workflow in which we
can actually do ahcs look at markers at
the chemistry
um
once this is an skbr which is fair to
positive cytokine 19
and this we wanted to really look how
sensitive our technology is so that we
move on to business on research
for instance if we use appcam we will
never capture such subtles like the
hs5780 because it is
negative
so
we managed to detect amplifications as
expected and
lines for instance if we look at sw48 we
know that there are the math and
gfr amplifications we see them at a
cellular level in the cell line itself
that's
that's normal okay
but then our interest was to actually
see these reflected in the exosomes from
which
the that are generated from these cells
sensitivity
so we started off with an again another
plaques here we have a six blocks
looking at ctcs
we have app cam cytochrome 19. we have a
fan one this is a marker that we really
work a lot on and
and we've shown
um that this is involved in early
invasiveness
so they'll have hair to their er because
we had breast cancer cell lines for this
particular study
and much one
and we use luminex technology to read
these
now what's interesting here we did a
titration experiment with different
cells so here you see the mfi
mean fluorescence intensity against some
number okay and here we have uh blues
apcam
orange is site okay 19 yellow is f and
one and green is
l2
now what we can see here if we look at
skvr which is l2 positive we can see
that the green one here too
okay
is very high uh cytokine is very high
upcoming is high
and it is negative for f and one so if
we for one we don't find these
if we use only appcam you can see that
the magnitude is not
um
as high as using
um the hair 2 and say to character 19.
so in this case
we of course promote the use of cytokine
19
and
and her2 for this particular surname
because we can actually direct down to
five cells here
with this quantity gene essay
was using this cell line you can see
that
again afghan is high but you you don't
deduct
lower than
four t cells
was with
r2 and
cetera at 19 we can go down to 15 cells
that all depends on the expression level
of these markers
now look at this this is total different
hs5 780 is negative for everything
except a fun one so and with f and one
we can even read five cents so
so the importance of multiplexing and
actually and
detecting these
ctcs
and then okay we moved on to exosomes
and here is where one of our industrial
partners only is working and helping us
with
is to put together a workflow
and
automated
workflow with
microfluidic
miniaturizations to increase the
sensitivity
so that we actually read the exosomes
and the plasma by
um immunoprecipitating them with
specific beads
[Music]
so the exosomes are these membrane-bound
extracellular vesicles from endosomal
origin if you can see electron
microscopy of these exosomes keep in
mind that exosomes are extremely small
so 30 to 120 nanometers if you have
something which is in the
sort of two microns those are apoptotic
bodies and then general microphysicals
are
sort of um indicating all these types
but we are working with exosomes now
exosomes are from endosomes so they have
specific markers so mainly we worked
with cd63 and cd9 yeah
we have uh streptavidin donor beads and
we buy it in late at the body which
would
bind to exosomes in this case it's acd-9
now we have of course the exosome
capture complex
and from this axon capture process we
are enriching the exosomes from plasma
okay and once they are captured then we
can also see these captured exosomes in
flow cytometry okay using for instance
and cd63 which is conjugated with the
phytase
and this is the exosome detection
complex that we see on flow cytometry
and it's easy to put together
okay you can look at cd63 if i to see
you can also use other markers like hair
tool if it is a hair to positive cell
this is what you see on a flow cytometry
you would have these single beads which
are loaded with exosomes you will see
the double beads and the triple beads
but even less and less every time so we
can gate on the single
and we can see actually the positivity
of these exosomes to cd63
when we spike these exosomes in blood
okay
so here we have we can see a shift and
this is the known noxism control against
the exosome sample so this is
hs578
produces exosomes we know that because
we measure them as well with nanosites
um and
but they are not 362 positive okay so
again importance of multiplexing to
actually
avoid
negative results
okay so then we moved on like okay if we
produce exosomes from these cell lines
what is the representation of these
panels and markers so if we look and we
run the quantity in say which is using
the mean median for sentence and
intensity
using afghan cytokine 19 fn1 and r2 as
kbr
it's positive
for
um
all of them
but the exosomes you can see cytokines
in 19 and 32 okay so the same trend
um but at a smaller scale okay but you
still actually can detect them
why is hs570 which is in this case for
this particular opinion only positive
for a fine one you also see the same
trend in the exosomes which are derived
from
this originator cell
and when you compare
40
different genes in the multiplex fashion
and here we have
identified and created
panels which we call crc amp for
amplifications and diagnosis
crc
invasion which are important
gene amplifications in the result
involved in invasion
and crc mets which are
in metastatic disease
so when we put them together
then we will find the the
the those that are amplified in this
particular cell line you have these
which are amplified and you can see that
if you plot the
the mfis from 250 nanograms of rna it
has a very nice regression with
with
lamborghs resulting from exosomes
now of course you'll find some outliers
but in general for gene amplifications
you will actually have this nice
correlation
so yes we can actually measure the gene
amplification in exosomes
that originate from specific
well we didn't stop there so we actually
have a step-up
method
a workflow to actually isolate them now
from patients
in addition we also can detect the amps
in 0.5 millimeters of ffbe cores
and as we showed the result before
primary versus metastatic tissues in
which we found these different
um gene amplifications
and metastasis but of interest then we
managed to detect this particular
foraging amplification in
some of our patient derived vectors
using only 0.5 mils of plasma
and
this is an effort between
our university and
and omnigene in which we are setting up
this simpliflex
assay to actually
isolate these exosomes and read them
from patient plasma
and crc
[Music]
so what we are currently what i put
together here is we're starting from
biology we understood that there is a
specific phosphatase and we can actually
look at specific markers
and those markers um we went into into
the interest of gene amplifications
because it was involved in gene
amplifications
and if i wanted to read cellular biology
at the tumor level but also in the tumor
derived
and
physical senses and blood
so we know that there are various
clinical unmet needs like equivocal
diagnosis heterogeneity of heterogeneity
of tumors
looking at the dynamics progression of
disease and resistance to therapy okay
um
there are also problems to validate not
the biomarkers and therefore
multiplexing and this high throughput
methods can be used to actually do that
from various sources
and of course we've here we're putting
together and put together an enabling
technology together with
term official luminex
as enablers
and we want a high accuracy precision we
most importantly and very important is
that we are getting a digitalized result
okay and which we actually can also
have use it for patient surveillance
because we can reach less than 15 cells
we can read exosomes now we know as well
okay we can measure
um markers in low quality material and
low input from ffpe
so this is all done and tested
so for these studies it was only
possible through the efforts of various
parties including the industrial
partners and the enablers luminex for
the xmap technology for the multiplexing
german fisher for their quantagine
essays
omnigene for putting together workflows
for the exosome
research then the whole research group
including christian sherry janice sherry
michelle cheichi
this one with
jessica de batista
the clinical consultants from the
pathology james the gaetano from surgery
charles cheney and the navigators who
took care of the consenting
and of course the patients that
consented to the study
and of course all this cannot happen
without funds therefore thank you to the
grant holders multi-council for science
and technology
and the ridt fund
and alive foundation
and with that i thank you and i open the
panel for any questions thank you very
much
thank you dr greg for that informative
presentation and we will now start the
live q a portion of this webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen so let's get started we
already have some great questions coming
in dr greg
an audience member says very interesting
can you explain what the added value of
this method is compared to other pcr
based gene expression methods
okay helen thank you and so here the pcr
based
methods of course will amplify the
templates meaning that
the template has to be
of adequate quality
and and in our hands when we compare
pcrb's technologies with the
quantitation technologies quantity gene
technologies do better
when the quality of the material is low
and
also of course if you look at
multiplexing then you can go up to 80
genes simultaneously with the quantity
genes
when was the gene expression profiles
methods like uh real-time pcr that's
limiting to the
number of channels on the machine
um
and in addition also like it's more
sensitive as i showed in the
presentation
we can also go down to detecting
five cells in a liquid biopsy setting
and that means that it is extremely
sensitive we could not
manage to do that with pcr methodologies
so i think the
answer to this question is that it is
advantageous for low quality material
because of advantages for low input
material
and also for multiplexing
up to 80 genes
and to know and you you of course you
can actually increase that as we go
along with technology development
thank you so much and can you clarify
the crc invasion panel and how this can
be used in a patient setting
okay so
we've
we started off with a panel of 40
gene amplifications in which we
run
various material and
and we have identified
specific areas in
sfpe materials and blocks patient blocks
and where we find a lot of heterogeneity
and therefore we have different sites
and one of these particular of
particular interests is actually where
we have the invasion front
and of the tumor itself
and here we identify specific gene
amplifications
and also i've shown that gene
applications actually also
change in
in a matter of
between primary tumors and metastatic
lesions
so
it is very versatile and the crc
invasion panel is very specific in that
case because it's about the invasion
front
of
the tumor
and that's one of the things that we
working on currently in fact we also put
up a number of cellular models which i
did not present today
and in which we have um
air response markers
for an invasion
and of course these being part of panels
like these would always be useful
and
although during innovation we might not
find circulating tumor cells within
liquid biopsies our hypothesis is that
exosomes we can actually detect also
early response genes
during tumor development
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in we have time for a
couple of more
this next question for the gene apple
amplifications in colorectal cancer can
one measure 40 genes in low input
material for example micro dissection
material
okay so the simple answer is yes but i
will explain as well so we actually did
a couple of experiments
uh and actually the first
when we when we put together this
methodology we also published and
section material
and paper in which we
we have
very low input and in that paper we also
read 40 genes so
we had a panel of 40 genes and we can
actually read them the interesting part
is
that we can use the quantity nation um
also
um on h e stain so h e stained material
from patients so you take the the slides
you age stain them and you actually can
eventually also micro dissect
accurately on stained materials and then
go
into the essay now one of the one of the
advantages is of course you don't need
to do rna extraction and you don't need
to do cdna extraction
and of course you don't need to amplify
the target which means it's a very um
short
workflow
and because of that shortwave flow you
you maximize
on the input materials because you don't
lose that much material when as when we
actually do um different
um
methods
to to get to our to our endpoint
measurement
so yes we do have we did work with micro
dissection materials but i would like to
add the point that we can also use
stained
micro dissection material so that you
can select the regions
more accurately
thank you so much and it looks like we
have one more question coming in and
this is a two-part question
um
can you use this methodology for peach
patient-derived xenograft models and
then the second part is what are the
advantages and proposed applications if
so
good um
yes
we did work in collaboration with other
institutions
in which we have
used patient-derived xenografts
and we actually set up whole tissue
microarrays and for the xenograft models
and
and
and the methodology can easily be used
of course for for this particular
material
and the advantages are the same as i
explained before you can do multiplexing
with various genes
um and
and the workflow is very short and the
sensitivity is extremely high so you can
actually use
uh also minimal input
for these um for these essays
dr greg i want to thank you for your
time and your presentation today would
you like to provide any closing remarks
before we go
um
yeah so so uh here of course it's a
merge of uh
of technologies
and i would like to uh sort of mention
that
the the
the use of
signal amplification
and beat based assays
in xmap technology which is a luminex
technology is is definitely a
something that we found to be very
useful in terms of
both
time and workflow because to do uh one
essay
and you really require an overnight
hybridization
step
and then the
the workflow is a three-hour workflow so
in three hours you can do 96 samples at
one go so um
with these technologies we found
ourselves very very um
with high efficiency and efficacy in
identifying glottal biomarkers and also
validating biomarkers in such a very
short workflow
dr greg i want to thank you again for
your time and for your important
research and before we go i also want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions i'd
also like to thank our sponsor luminix
for sponsoring today's webinar questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand for two years
until september
2023 labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event and until next time
take care everyone stay safe bye-bye
thank you